james carafano right now of the heritage
foundation foreign policy expert james
if you think of of china and how how
much its economy and strength even its
military prowess has been built on the
you know financial or you know deals it
has had with all these western nations
whether it likes them or not uh that's
their bread and butter why would they
risk
compromising that seeing the same kind
of sanctions that russia has
to join this fight and a fight we're
told that they really kind of wince at
in the performance of vladimir putin in
general
yeah so i i think you're asking the
wrong questions it's like what would
they risk the chinese don't want to risk
anything here's here's the two things
that we think we know for sure one is
the last thing china wants is to see
russia humiliated russia is their
stalking horse in europe they were
looking to russia to drive a weaken and
divided and distracted europe that would
actually be a better target for
china so russia is doing their work for
them they they would hate to see that be
dramatically reserved the other thing is
look china will do anything it can for
russia that it can't be held accountable
for so you better believe whatever they
do they will try to disguise it in a way
not to give people a clear shot at them
here's the problem with everything i've
just heard from everybody who just said
well we might do this this is
the russians
and the chinese and the iranians they
react to what we do
not what we say
if you want to get their attention you
have to do something to them if we
really wanted to prevent china from
aiding russia we would have hammered
them at the start of the war and held
them accountable and
and
and then and then they would have to
come back to us and beg for relief
threatening them just says just signals
to them either should i ignore this or
how can i work around this or how can i
make sure my defenses are good so i can
survive this this is this is
statecraft malfeasance
well james we were late to the party on
and enacting a lot of those sanctions
very very early on uh but it is what it
is and now china can see the sweeping
sanctions and financial measures taken
do you think they look at that and say
uh that's one thing we don't want that's
one thing uh whether we're being overt
about the aid and the help buying
russian oil uh you know after sanctions
kick in uh but certainly nothing's over
to trigger the same response because
it's one thing to hit russia that way
for china it's quite another what do you
think
yeah but but what you've just done is
signaled to them a problem to work their
way around so they can hide it
they can go to countries now and
threaten them and say if you go along
with the americans we will hammer you
this they can go and bribe people so so
the point is is by just saying i might
do something you are telegraphing to the
enemy exactly what they what they know
that they have to work around how would
china do
just to be clear how would china do that
another how would it it would try to
find a third-party way to get weapons or
military help it's already acknowledged
i guess and you're the expert that
they're going to make up or try to make
up for a lot of the loss of oil
customers russia is going to have it
can't come close to to losing the world
as it stands right but how will china
play this
right so the first thing they will do is
they will do everything possible under
the table so it's not readily apparent
and then if it is done they will deny it
to give people plausible deniability not
to make the hard decisions to sanction
them then the other thing they're going
to do is they're going to run around
they're going to they're going to have
talk to countries through the back door
and they're going to threaten them that
if they go along with the united states
that they will be a repercussions for
this because
the one thing the chinese are still
banking on is that the world has a short
memory and once they get through this
very painful experience with ukraine
that that the united states and the west
will just go back to doing business with
china and sleepwalk through history and
they just want to remind people that
after all this stuff's off the front
pages they will still be there so
they've got a lot of cards to play and
every time we let we we let them decide
what to do and then we react to that
this you're violating the first rule of
warfare which is make your enemy respond
to you not the other way around
well put james carrafano thank you very
much my friend hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else